en medio de la noche levantan las
trampas que yacen en el fondo del canal
de la mancha en el interior centollos se
venderán al día siguiente en los
mercados del contenta una vez que el
animal está metido en el barco las cajas
vuelven al mar hasta el próximo paso del
cabo lizar arañas pero también vecinos
la operación se repite durante horas y
como la mayoría de las tripulaciones con
base en el puerto normando de cárter es
la mayoría de los caladeros están en
aguas territoriales de jersey
así que cuando gregory del alone y sus
hombres se enteraron de que el break sit
significaba el fin de la licencia para
pescar en esta zona marítima la noticia
llegó como un auténtico mazazo
lo supimos en el último momento durante
el mes de diciembre no sabíamos que iba
a pasar en enero nos dijeron que iba a
haber licencias para ciertos barcos
[Música]
con el 60% de los sitios donde pescamos
pertenecen a sus aguas territoriales
solo nos quedará la franja porque
quieren hacerse con toda esta parte
hasta ahora unos trescientos cuarenta
barcos de normandía y bretaña pescaban a
diario en aguas de jersey
la salida del reino unido de la unión
europea el 31 de diciembre puso fin al
tratado de la bahía de granville que les
permitía este acceso desde 2004 la
mayoría de los pescadores pasaron el mes
de enero en tierra bajo la presión de
las autoridades francesas y europeas la
isla del canal les ha permitido
provisionalmente regresar hasta el 30 de
abril pero después de esta fecha el
futuro es incierto valentón que
trabajaba en el cabo lizar junto a su
padre de nicolás teme que toda su forma
de vida esté ahora amenazada
mi bisabuelo era pescador y mi padre es
pescador mi hermano espectador en
cárceles así que somos una familia de
pescadores imaginemos que uno quiere
empezar o lo que sea no estará fácil
para los jóvenes que van a tomar el
relevo no será nada fácil en cualquier
caso no nos dejaremos esa es la cuestión
también no podemos dejarnos si no nos
podemos vivir más cómo podremos ganarnos
la vida
si no nos dejan trabajar en casa no les
dejaremos desembarcar así que será una
guerra interminable sabiendo que el 70
de su pescado se desembarca en francia
tampoco podrán vivir
entonces en sus aguas no hay otra manera
solo tenemos que someternos a las
condiciones al final la comisión europea
decide se fundan de acuerdo con ella
muy serio
si se pescan tanto en aguas francesas
como en las del jersey estos vinos que
se exportan a todos los rincones del
mundo llevan el nombre de bahía de
granville
un patrimonio económico y cultural común
a todo este corredor marítimo de apenas
30 kilómetros de ancho que ahora depende
de las altas esferas de europa los
comités regionales de pesca que
participaron en las discusiones
constante ley ven que las cosas se le
salen de las manos
era el estado francés el que dentro del
límite de una cuota máxima asignaba la
licencia de pesca para los normandos y
los vectores ahora jerzy quien dice que
no ahora yo soy quien las da
y tratar del circuito muy complicado
ahora entra aquí el campo parís parís
bruselas bruselas londres londres santé
mier y al revés así que todo esto es
terriblemente engorroso al punto de que
el mundo pesquero sobre el terreno ya no
entiende en absoluto
a pesar de las complicaciones no hay
tiempo que perder
antes de finales de abril hay que
presentar una lista de embarcaciones con
pruebas de su presencia previa en agua
de jersey
en el puerto de cárter luz y limón del
comité de pesca de normandía intenta
recopilar toda la información posible de
los datos de las balizas son una prueba
bastante con el cliente y su estancia en
aguas inglesas por otro lado hay barcos
geolocalizados que son la mayoría en
nuestra zona porque son barcos pequeños
pues no tenemos ese tipo de cosas así
que nos toca trabajar con los pescadores
para recuperar las pruebas que son sus
declaraciones de pesca las
investigaciones que hacemos con ellos
todo lo que podamos encontrar pero
activista donde su voto es atrapados en
la tormenta de la burocracia post break
ship los pescadores de normandía esperan
no quedarse en el muelle y quieren creer
en un retorno a la situación anterior
casi 750 de estos pescadores y más de
2.000 empleos indirectos podrían verse
afectados por la prohibición del acceso
a las aguas de hershey